workout review workout review hello
everyone today we're going to go through
my epic workout so you also can look
epic game
someone posted this on my Reddit so dude
that looks Photoshop I don't even Is
that real
blue
but maybe not uh I don't I don't really
feel comfortable doing like a before and
after I don't want to do that uh but
yeah I wanted to talk about my workout
so hopefully you guys can get inspired
as well I made a workout video a year
and a half ago and uh so I wanted to
talk about what has changed what has
improved what has worked what didn't
work or if anything's changed at all
first off let's go through my setup my
workout setup which is the same goddamn
setup that I've always had and here's
why Jim said it
hey there spots me thank you very much
for doing that the only difference now
is that I'm in our living room I just
put in my mat I put in my thingy
schmingi and I put in my weights I keep
them behind our couch so we don't have
to see them like I don't want to make
our living room messier than it is
that's all you need baby I use these
weights called power block it's the same
one I always had but a friend of mine
gifted me uh the newer ones I refused to
buy the newer ones I don't know why I'm
so cheap guys I don't know what's wrong
with me I could have just they kept
breaking and bending I went to a welder
guy and he fixed them but they didn't
really fix them I had to use like a
screwdriver to pry them open every time
and I was just losing a bunch of time in
my workout so I'm glad the newer ones
are way better of the power blocks it's
just a way so you can change the weights
really quickly I personally really enjoy
working out with dumbbells so
considering a whole rack of dumbbells
will probably set you back a couple
thousand this is definitely like a
cheaper version I hope once I'm more
settled in I can actually justify
investing in some equipment because uh
yeah since I'm supposed to move abroad I
I just haven't my workout is pretty much
more or less the same as I used to I've
only changed up a couple of things here
and there I think I used to do five days
a week but I have actually moved down to
four days a week I start off
like most people with chest gotta start
up with chess it's the best
so this would be my Monday I start off
with the regular bench press I'm
struggling to get picked
for once I'm filming myself I can't do
it I've actually maxed out my uh I maxed
out my dumbbells that was an amazing
moment I might actually had to spot me
the thing with dumbbells is they're
quite hard to get up like to get to the
position this position
uh to do that on your own when you're
maximizing it's really difficult I have
to psych myself up a little bit every
time
and this is pathetic push you in my leg
like that's not helping
it's more about getting in the right
position but yeah
um I was so proud when I hit the my new
record and then I Googled like
how good is that and it basically said
like for your weight group intermediate
and I was like what the [ __ ] I expected
to read like God mode or Giga chat or
some [ __ ] so it became clear to me that
I I need to put on more weight to lift
more weight
um so that's why I I've been trying to
bulk up more I've always been quite
skinny so
yeah you can do one more
yeah let's go
it's perfect for him
I definitely been pushing myself more I
think if I had to show my progress like
on a graph if this is where I was when I
made my video a year ago I think I've
kind of like it went up a little bit and
then I kind of like
became a bit more lazy I just did my
workout for the sake of it and I did
that for a long time with the goal of
just being consistent you know getting
my workout done I wasn't really pushing
myself that hard but I was also okay
with that but only until recently I've
really started pushing myself more than
I have ever have and that's actually
been really really fun I try to push
myself to the point where it's like okay
here I am one more ramp if I could do
one more ramp there will be world peace
and everyone will be happy and it's like
no sorry I can't do it but yeah so I do
chance I do incline chest
which is good too and then I do
a third set of chest when it's
I don't go down all the way
after that I Do shoulders
which ones when you're already tired
from chest shoulder is quite difficult
but it still feels amazing
um
I'm really struggling it's kind of funny
I never seen myself work out before
oh yeah and then after that I do a
superset where I combine oh yeah look at
that these I don't know what they call
this tricep and then uh lateral raises I
guess like that
I guess I'm resting a little bit in
between but I try to make it into one
set
I don't wanna
get too tired
I finally come to a point where I'm more
comfortable pushing myself before if I
ever felt like I'm pushing myself so I
could almost throw up which which can
happen I think especially when you're
building muscle like happy happen easier
than you think uh and that's just not a
place I want to be uh I want to feel
good with my workout but I I know kind
of where my limit is so it if I do feel
tired I don't I'm not too bothered just
stopping a little bit you know yeah and
that's pretty much my Monday I guess the
first day of my workout it takes me
about an hour more or less to complete I
would say probably 50 minutes and then I
do uh around eight minute abs afterwards
to wrap it all up if you're still here
listening can you guys do me a favor so
I was supposed to promote the new G fuel
tub like it's awesome it's by the artist
for tuber simulator and legend of the
brofist if you get this new tub there's
a 30 discount if you enter the code of
PewDiePie and you can also get this new
shaker very nice love G fuel it's the
greatest I drink every day
10 muscle increase of course the
PewDiePie layer is just so damn good
like there's so many great flavors in G
fuel but it's also the most relevant
flavor I deleted my video where I was
promoting it because I didn't like the
video
so if you guys can uh just just buy it
from this promo so hopefully G full
doesn't notice that I deleted the video
okay thank you enter code PewDiePie I
appreciate it
it's good drink okay it's not a
pre-workout it's just epic drink epic
gamer drink moving on to the next day
number two Tuesday is leg day baby
and do squat
with my perfect form okay I don't want
to hear anyone complaining about my form
because I don't care
four sets of squat and then there were
four sets of deadlift barefooted
deadlift don't drop it on your toes it's
kind of awkward doing that lift with
dumbbells I'm not a huge fan but hey it
does the trick and oh mama do I get
tired from it I I know it's a bit cringe
but I did film myself
what's my heart rate
I can't see you didn't film it you idiot
I guess I don't know if I'm doing it
wrong you know what don't answer that
the thing is leg just kills me it's my
shortest workout I think it takes me
only 45 minutes but it absolutely
destroys me like is this weird thing
where while I'm doing it I'm not that
tired but as soon as I stop I'm just
like I need to sit down oh God
no one likes leg day if you like leg day
you're lying okay but so I try to make
it quick but intense just to get it out
after that lift I do the split squat
thing lunges that's it three sets of
that and then I do the calf raises where
you go on your toes blah blah blah blah
blah blah and then I'm pretty much done
you know I don't I'm not that you know
legs yeah sure it's done it's done I
don't care more first two days are quite
intense that's why I rest on the third
day and on the third day I should be
feeling really like I've worked out I
should be feeling my legs and I should
be feeling my upper body still it's a
good day to rest there I think because
my whole body is pretty much in pain at
that point but it's a wonderful feeling
if you work out regularly especially you
don't it's hard to get that but if your
workouts to the point where your whole
body is literally in pain that's a great
reminder that you had a you put in the
effort you put in the work you put in
the hours man uh it's a good kind of
pain to have I love it then on day four
I do I start off a little bit slower
again where I do uh pulls and the great
thing about working out at home is I can
be shirtless and it's not cringe
so I I start off with the single arm
rows then I do two arm rows
then I do overhead extension
[Music]
and then I do just double arm rows but
reverse grip then I do biceps and then I
do uh hammer curls that's probably my
easiest workout it's kind of hard
finishing up with bicep and hammer curls
because you're kind of tired at that
point but what I find to really elevate
my work at is my Spotify playlist where
I listen to a bunch of like industrial
techno or like metal or heavy metal or
or black metal
mixed with some really cringy music like
Euro techno you're a pop I don't know
what to call it from like 2000 with like
DJ Alice and [ __ ] like that because you
want to start off with the Duke Duke
like really heavy [ __ ] but then once you
get tired and you need to pull through
those last few sets you put on that Euro
Euro disco techno [ __ ]
that real cringy music but once you're
it sounds so cringe but once you were
there doing those bicep curls and that
do you think you're better off alone or
you're just like yeah
it works okay it [ __ ] works 20 muscle
increase 10 from G fuel I guess that's
the thing with that with this craft too
like I used to listen to like podcasts
and maybe YouTube videos sometimes just
like whatever in the background and I
don't think that makes you as focused as
when you if you put on music that you
really like it really motivates you and
like it forces you to kind of push
yourself a bit more and I gotta be
honest like my goal with the my work at
is to just be consistent more than
anything so while I am you know really
pushing myself now I am allowing myself
to understand that even if I do later on
go down again that's totally fine as
long as I'm staying consistent with it
because that's the oh the long-term goal
is for me to just keep going no matter
what I don't want to fall off and I'm
not planning to I'm like my goal is to
keep this on forever because I I just
love it so much when I'm in a in a
workout where you're so tired that you
literally we have nothing else left in
you and all you can do is really just
like I don't I didn't film it because
it's not authentic but you push yourself
to a point where all you have left is to
just scream that to me is a beautiful
moment because it means you're pushing
yourself to your limit you're fully
concentrated in what you're doing uh
you're overcoming yourself as someone
that's quit drinking I quit nicotine so
those are usually things that makes you
feel like oh dopamine good but that
moment when you're you're pushing
yourself to your limit while working out
it gives me that same sort of almost
spiritual feeling I I could say I love
it it's very addicting it's just a pure
moment of concentration of pain I would
say I don't know what to call it then uh
after I do my pull exercises day five is
I used to do leg on day five but I just
feel like I don't need to do legs twice
a week that's just me I think my legs
looks just fine and I'm not particularly
that passionate about legs
so what I like to do is uh uh sometimes
I do Kendo which I found to be a really
fun kind of cardio to be honest it it
kind of tires you out pretty well and
it's fun to try out something different
uh I've been following like tutorials
online I'm sure Kendall Bros are just
like he's doing everything wrong
I really enjoy it before that I used to
do other stuff as well I was jump
skipping Joe what's it called jumping
rope I kind of see it as my I can do
whatever I want day and I do that for
literally just 40 to 30 to 40 minutes
and that's a really good workout and
it's really fun to try out something
different as well I'm I'm not entirely
sure I will keep that up to be honest
but I'm also okay with that then on my
last day day six I really like to finish
strong and I do a workout that's sort of
a combination of the entire week except
leg of course because leg is cringe I do
chest I do shoulder I do bicep I do all
the Epic stuff and it's my favorite
workout yeah you definitely feel it the
day after which is really nice so that's
why I rest on the day after there's a
lot of stuff like small tips and well
mindset stuff that you might think and
that's not gonna make a difference and
it probably isn't but I I find myself to
be with work at it's so easy to make
excuses for yourself like Oh I'm a bit
tired today or um yesterday I had blah
blah blah or today was a long day or
blah blah blah you come up with all
these excuses of why you shouldn't work
out I don't want to sound like toxic
like you have to work out my mind it's
more like it's easy to get in that
mindset so I like to have other stuff to
kind of
it seems silly but they help counteract
those sort of uh self-pitying thoughts I
guess one thing I have that really
really helps is my watch because I can
time my sets and I can see my heartbeat
to make sure I'm not working too hard or
I'm working enough you know and as an
epic minimalist you might ask how do you
justify having a watch I try to use my
phone I try using an app to tie my wraps
but it it's dangerous to be on your
phone while you're walking out because
you're just it's so easy oh oh
notification start talking to people uh
it still happens but it's better not to
touch your phone during your workout so
that's why I like to have my my watch
and it's really really helpful to have
that it's the sole reason I have this
watch it's just for that so I don't
touch my phone through my workout
another good thing about it is that I
can time my workout so I know how long
it takes to know that I'm not slacking
or being sloppy and also you know when
you work out on your own at home it's
kind of hard to start sometimes
especially when you're in your living
room you're not in the right mindset
right away and you kind of start
dragging you're you're like uh I'll
start soon but if I start the timer on
my watch it's like no now I have to
start another thing I do is I drink uh
pre-workout sometimes I even drink G
fuel just because I know jifa is not a
pre-workout but it's more like okay I
drank it now I have to work out I did
something now I have to start my workout
because sometimes I just find myself
wasting time and that's not what you're
supposed to be doing of course no
substances no steroids steroids that
goes completely against my whole
philosophy on workout if other people
want to do it great good for you but me
nah no thanks I used to write down my my
weights in this book but uh I don't
really feel like I need to do that
anymore it's really good to do that I
definitely recommend doing that but I I
feel like I know my weights and I don't
really have to but yeah going on before
with like making excuses is it's easy to
start feeling pity and like oh no I
shouldn't um and I yeah I really don't
want to promote some sort of toxic like
uh push yourself too hard mindset
because I'm not about that at all I just
know that it's easy to make excuses
sometimes and I think everyone is
different some people don't feel good by
pushing themselves but I always know I
feel way worse if I skip something as
opposed to just pushing myself through
it maybe at 80 or 70 percent instead of
doing nothing feeling pity over yourself
is kind of a pointless emotion it's not
going to help you with anything really
so I think it's good to overcome that
it's the pain that gives you the
strength after all it's kind of funny
how it works with that not just from the
typical gym like no pain no gain it
works the exact same with your mind some
philosophical notes there's a famous
quote from Socrates that says no citizen
has a right to be an amateur in the
matter of physical training what a
disgrace it is for a man to grow old
without saying that Beauty and strengths
of of which his body is capable of
Socrates I think this quote is kind of
taken from a time where there was a lot
of war and Greece needed to be defended
so I I would take it with a with a grain
of salt but I think also the way we live
now especially sort of the Mind precedes
the body our body is just sort of a suit
for our brain to travel in when in
reality they're deeply connected and to
experience growth and pain in in both
ways combined I think is something
especially now where there's no
practical using any of it is a wonderful
thing you know everyone's canvas is
different everyone's possibility is
different but it's what you do with it
that matters you know a lot of people
look at work and within in philosophy
with the idea of niche's ubermench but
for me it's more of rising above Taro
sustra the idea of the last man like I
said before
um I think we live in a time where where
the mind precedes the body and I don't
want to live in a way where I'm always
comfortable or I'm not taking risks or
pushing myself and just simply keeping
keeping warm as it said and then I feel
like my results with my workout doesn't
matter as much as the point of me
pushing myself and I think that goes for
for everything really I don't remember
if it's Aristotle or soccer test but it
they basically lay out the idea with
about virtue that it's it's in what
we're doing it's not what we have done
and I think that's something really nice
because especially with with people that
work out I notice there's a feeling of
more I need to gain more muscle I need
to become more strong or I need to
become more built when in reality that
way you'll never be satisfied the point
of working out and I think this should
be motivating for people that maybe
haven't started or or want to get
started as long as you're doing it
that's all that matters you're putting
in the same effort as anyone else who's
at the gym or whatever the point is that
you're doing it not that you haven't
reached your goal yet I would really
focus on that night I think that's such
a better mindset that it works really
well for me like I don't think about
what I haven't achieved yet I'm just
really happy once I do it and that's why
I try to work out in the sense that
consistency is what matters more than
anything but I really really enjoyed
pushing myself more lately I find that
to be really really fun I'm enjoying my
workout more now than ever it's probably
the closest thing to any sort of
spiritual feeling that I could achieve
right I love it
um and I hope other people can
experience it as well so what are you
waiting for get on out there you got
nothing to lose is good for your health
and your mind anytime you work out you
feel better and it doesn't have to be
strength building anyway like like I
said on my fourth day I do whatever like
Kendo that's a good workout [ __ ] even
just jumping rope or doing a sport you
know it's it's always better doing
something than nothing and I guess
that's another thing that a lot of the
stoics talked about as well especially
with workout that whatever it is doing
some sort of workout and they figured
this out thousands of years ago which is
that wherever it's doing regular
physical workout is living a better life
because you are making a better choices
as a consequence and it's better for
your health as well I don't want to have
anyone to feel guilty or feel shitty
about not exercising but I think it's
always better to do a little bit than
nothing and then you can slowly if you
start to feel comfortable then you can
start pushing yourself a little bit but
I'll start simple it doesn't have to be
that much it could be
um just a couple minutes a day you know
if you start looking at it like oh I'm I
need to work out because I need to be in
this type of body shape or whatever then
you're missing the point the point
should be my goal is to keep being
consistent with it and doing every day I
don't know anyway thanks for watching
check out the g-fuel guys so you get 30
off I really appreciate it and that's it
bye bye